i made my first fifty thousand dollar
purchase of bitcoin today everyone's
saying how come you didn't do it two
weeks ago i'm in okay so uh
you gotta tell me is the crypto winter
over
well it doesn't matter i'm just happy
you're in so major congrats charles it's
great to have you part of our of our
community so look i don't even think
this was a crypto winter this level of
volatility is actually very normal
particularly in a bull market this is
crypto after all and so i actually think
things are starting to heat up the level
of adoption that we're seeing right now
is really incredible whether it's el
salvador an entire country adopting
bitcoin as legal tender whether it's
politicians like the mayor of miami
taking their salary in bitcoin whether
it's senator ted cruz investing in
bitcoin beloved tv personalities like
yourself investing in bitcoin you know
so things really are just starting to
heat up and to be honest i don't really
want to see any kind of parabolic
explosion in price right now at all
because that's usually followed by very
sharp snapbacks which isn't very healthy
i'd much prefer to see a slow climb even
moving sideways i'd be happy with i just
want to see some consolidation and some
support you know on that notion that you
just mentioned the the adoption and the
recognition there's a great article this
morning from historian neil ferguson who
by the way is the author of two of my
favorite books the ascent of money and
civilization where he says sooner or
later a respectable central bank is
going to admit to owning bitcoin and
that could open up flood games for
adoption do you agree this is a pretty
interesting one because i think that the
west you know like the fed for example
and the bank of england aren't going to
want to let go of the control that they
have over monetary policy just yet given
bitcoin is censorship resistant it's
decentralized and was intended to be
traded peer-to-peer it does have the
ability to disintermediate these major
institutions and so they're not going to
be able to just print as much money as
they want so i don't think they're going
to want to give up that level of control
of turkey though or something like that
though like not not the western ones but
you know those who are trying to you
know they have a delicate balancing act
weak economies uh they can't really
print and get any traction printing your
own currency could you see a bank of
turk a central bank of turkey or
something like that
absolutely this is what i was going to
get to i think that countries who are in
unfortunate dire straits will have to
look to bitcoin as the alternative you
know we've already seen the president of
el salvador go to turkey speak with
their president supposedly about bitcoin
and actually i wouldn't be surprised if
we saw lebanon for example um start
having these bitcoin conversations
because the lebanese pound has lost 90
of its value since the beginning of uh
2019. yeah and lebanon of course used to
be uh the one of the world's financial
senators beirut all right he also writes
by the way that defy looks like a bona
fide financial revolution and it reminds
him of the period after the black death
in the mid 14th century and of course
again he's one of the best historians on
this the adoption of money i mean your
thoughts when you hear that
i totally agree and i absolutely love
this because actually we're living
through a time where censorship is rife
where we are seeing um you know free a
war on freedom of speech we are seeing
the establishment actually confiscate
money of democratic protesters who are
just trying to protest for their freedom
inflation is booming and of course
cbdc's are coming so right now people
could actually say times are pretty dark
and although it's a cliche bitcoin does
tend to fix this because of its
underlying technology because it is
censorship resistant because it has a
limited supply and so charles no matter
how much money they print no matter how
many lockdowns they implement and also
no matter how many medicines they
require us to get in order to
participate in society they can never
confiscate our bitcoin that will always
be ours and so we often look at bitcoin
as this technology which kind of really
becomes symbolic of being able to remove
the shackles of authoritarian and
tyrannical government policy